a hub is just a repeater that goes in
many directions you could call it
multi-directional or you could call it a
multi-port that would be the same thing
but it's just a repeater that goes all
those ways okay so here's the way would
work um you've got one known you're
sitting at one computer okay and there's
a hub in the middle of a star network
okay so you're connected to it this
computer is connected to it this
computer is connected to it this
computer is getting to it okay you send
a message you want to get to say you
want to talk to fall for is it's okay
this is you you send your message to the
hub now what the hub will do what the
hub will do is it will read the signal
that you set and will interpret it try
and guess what you're actually saying
and then will resend it but what just
reset it along the next step of the
chain it will actually resend it to
everyone okay so it's kind of like a
loudspeaker like you know where if roses
picture this as me okay and for instance
suppose I was a bit of a a bit of a
delinquent parent okay and I lost my
daughter at the shops okay now what
would I do
I don't know where she is okay maybe
she's in this shop maybe she did that
one who knows okay so what do I do
I go to center management okay and I say
you know very sheepishly
kind of lost my daughter right and what
would they do what they do what would
they do have you ever heard this kind of
thing right you hear everyone's sort of
minding their own business with their
shopping and calls and then over the
loudspeaker the harp okay you hear an
announcement says would you know sort or
please your pin your parrot has lost you
and it's way too you know said to
management that kind of thing and all
the rest of the people like but they
ignore the message because they see it's
not intended for them and the person
hopefully who is intended for will
realize McKay this message was sent out
to everyone but it's for me okay so they
read it they interpret it and then they
respond accordingly okay so this is what
a hub is like a hub is like a
loudspeaker right in real life but in
terms of network infrastructure
I think it's closest to is a repeater
it's just a repeater that goes in lots
of directions it's multi-directional
okay no sorry ah the next one was a
switch a switch a switch
now we were toward that switches before
but we were talking about switches in
reference to the telephone network and I
had a thing called a switchboard
remember what that meant what is I refer
to what is a switchboard what's the job
of a switchboard that's right okay so
it's a similar kind of scenario to this
right you got one central guy or woman
okay who picks up it's like operator and
then says who do you want to connect to
okay and they'll switch the connections
in whichever direction that we need okay
so it's a little bit like this person
can change you know rail tracks to send
your data in the right direction okay so
what is a switch add a switch is like a
hub with control over its direction
okay that's a switch